all kinds of things sex revenge and the
selfishness I don't know all kinds of
things motivate creativity I would say
we are at a time though you have to be
commercially responsible you there's
less shelf space and there's more static
so you have to for every time you have
your opportunity to strike you it's
incumbent to be more precise so you
can't be completely in an ivory tower
creating things I'm much more of a
populist I much I relish in the idea of
reminding myself about my roots where I
come from my I didn't train in proper
fashion school I didn't graduate a
university and and the my financial you
know access today if I were to design
within that frame of reference I would
be I would lose my customer so I love
being able to remind myself of real
people I I feel like validation comes
from consumption right I know that
sounds a little cynical right like
validation maybe comes from really good
design as well but if you could strike
that balance of good design good value
and something cool and fun for your
consumer then I think you're really in
the pocket and I I much rather designed
for real people and be a populist about
hi approach
you